regardez ce site regarder cette page
décrypte un radio canada lance
aujourd'hui une section dédiée à la
vérification des faits et à la
désinformation sur le web l'équipe
s'appelle justement décrypteurs elle est
composée des journalistes javier
débouchera boîtier qui sont avec nous ce
matin bonjour à vous deux
tout de suite vous remercier d'être avec
nous et puis de de faire ce genre de
travail là parce que dieu sait qu'avec
une campagne électorale qui s'en vient
il va en avoir quelques-uns de ses de
ces propos alors bush a dit nous d'abord
que la qu'elle sera de la mission des
décrypteurs donc c'est de vérifier ce
qui circule sur internet ce qui circule
dans les réseaux sociaux et qui est faux
donc ce qu'on appelle communément les
forces nouvelles ont ça peut être des
canulars des photomontages truc et ça
peut être des fois des trucs un peu plus
gros comme on l'a vu dans les dernières
campagnes électorales des fois des
campagnes massives de désinformation et
aussi on va faire des dossiers un peu
plus gros pour essayer de comprendre
pourquoi est ce que les gens croient aux
fausses nouvelles comment les les
fausses nouvelles comment les campagnes
d information sur castres et aussi des
fois on va mettre en lumière un peu des
phénomènes qui émerge sur le web on sait
le web d'un lui a beaucoup de
polarisation de phénomène un peu louche
donc on va essayer d'expliquer un peu
ces phénomènes de la sriw en mesure de
nous dire par exemple que c'est l'objet
d'une organisation qui a bien conçues
sont re ou c'est un innocent qui a tout
simplement retransmis quelque chose qui
partage qui pensent être vain on va
tenter de savoir donc on va on va
s'intéresser
c'est vraiment c'est ce qu'on fait de
plus en plus pas simplement vérifier les
faits en question mais voir d'où sa
première parce que souvent c'est
organisé donc il ya des gens qui vont
créer par exemple des faux comptes sur
twitter ou facebook pour tenter de
propager une fausse information
pas toujours facile de savoir qui se
cache derrière ces choses là mais on va
faire notre mais bon on mettrait bien
vous publiez déjà un article aujourd'hui
c'est sur une fausse nouvelle qui
continue de tourner 2
le 15 peut-être que les habitants leur
ont déjà vu passer donc ça dit que le
maire de dorval refusé de bénir la part
des cantines scolaires alors que des
étudiants musulmans le demandent et les
membres au québec n'ont aucun droit de
regard sur ce qui se passe dans les
écoles bien sûr même s'il faut même si
tous les médias presque au québec que
l'on a démenti ce circuit depuis 2015
juste pour donner une idée le gérer sans
sont au moins 400 milles partage sur
facebook
oui donc on a juste à trouver d'où sa
provenance est une particule de vérité
là dedans donc c'est une vraie histoire
en france on a tout simplement changé le
nom de la ville pour dorval et depuis ce
temps là ça s'emballe mais j'entends nos
collègues de france info qui font le
même travail que vous et souvent on
prend une photo aux états unis on le
traduit on change quelques quelques
informations et souvent le bal repas
comme ça bon choix vous allez travailler
sur d'autres nouvelles bien sûr ce qui
est des projets sur lesquels vous êtes
actuellement la rampe la wii donc
justement moi je m'intéresse c'est donc
dans un dossier qui est à venir la
semaine prochaine sur pourquoi est ce
qu'on croit aux fausses nouvelles on
peut tous les biais psychologiques qu'on
l'a parce que parfois il ya des gens
dont qui sont vraiment mal intentionnés
qui vont orchestré des fausses nouvelles
des campagnes des photos qu'ils savent
qu'ils sont fausses mais après tous ces
gens qui vont les reprendre et qui vont
les partager sans vraiment savoir que
c'est faux et mais qui vont voir une
fausse nouvelle qui vont tout la
partager sans la vérifier parce qu'ils
vont avoir l'impression que c'est vrai
et parfois comme des faits démontrent
dans son article même quand on leur dit
que c'est faux il faut ils sont comme
lui mais c'est pas grave nous arrive
quand on réplique à nos articles qu'on
met sur facebook ou twitter
il faut expliquer et journalisme
argumenter avec eux c'est ça parce que
si les gens veulent croire que c'est
vrai donc je vais explique un peu
pourquoi est-ce qu'on a évolué un peu à
être vulnérable à ça parce que parfois
les gens qui vraiment innocemment vont
partager une fausse nouvelle ils vont
pas savoir que c'est fou donc c'est
important aussi pour le public de un peu
d'être plus vigilants et de comprendre
de quoi se méfier quand tu vois circuler
des choses qu est-ce qui devrait allumer
une lumière pour peut-être que ça c'est
faux bond jeff pour vous aider vous deux
voulait simplement voir des pis le
public a peut-être des indices et digère
succès sur ce bilan on fait comment pour
vous contacter au vous dire oui
donc pour nous écrire décrypteurs au
pluriel avec un s à rabat radio ser
canada.ca on a aussi un groupe facebook
décrypteurs au pluriel un prévenu on va
discuter des sujets aussi on recherche
vraiment si vous voyez des choses
logiques sur le web vous avez des
questions ça va nous faire un plaisir de
répondre
ils sont venus voir vos chose on va on
les trouve ou vos reportages les textes
et tout doit donc il ya une section qui
est lancée ce matin sur le site internet
de radio canada.ca donc c'est radio
canada.ca barres obliques décrypteurs
donc tous nos articles qu'on le voit
publiés à partir de maintenant mais
aussi des articles qu'on le fait dans
les dernières semaines parce qu'elle
jeff et moi on travaille depuis
longtemps à la dessus sur tout ouais
vous pourrez vraiment c'est le point de
rencontre sur tout ce qui touche des
informations fausses nouvelles théories
du complot je pense souvent à côté de
l'or dans leurs bureaux laissez moi vous
dire je les vois à leur ordinateur
constamment en train de sécurité ce qui
se passe merci beaucoup d'être une
voirie pour le travail que vous allez
faire ça va nous être utile à tous revus
à la prochaine merci à voir